that's occurring that's productive
dialogue you're here to shut me down hey
Maddie we'll be right back it's gonna be
a little longer than I anticipated so
tomorrow we'll be releasing a new
installment of change my mind on the
topic of abortion and in these as you
know we usually sit down and rationalize
our position but sometimes as you've
seen in the past some folks aren't
interested in that and a conversation
needs to take place just this life at
conception right but I disagree with
that nowadays okay do you mind if I just
ask a real quick oh I'll be right back
he knows me
[Applause]
okay why just because I noticed that you
were yelling and protesting I thought
maybe it's some opinions that you'd like
to voice well we actually have a lady
there who disagrees with me on probably
nearly everything but we're having a
productive discussion why do you think
you can productive discussion where you
make all the questions and she has to
unpack all the questions no oh really
would you like to ask me a question
really yeah would you like to ask me
questions you can sit down right after
Maddie just a here's a question why are
you a mouthpiece for the alt light
what's the opener
why are you a gateway point for all
right politics how so oh how so how so
dude I listen to Stephen all the time in
a mother you know you're an Ivy yeah
you're he's one of those notorious black
Nazis
I don't understand the question well let
me know since you said you watched the
program I don't know where you line up
would you consider me all right I mean
would you consider me it was that
implying I'm a racist I don't would you
consider anything I've done racist no
what does that mean I don't understand
the accusation is it means the people
like you ben shapiro
[Music]
light switch after friday at 6 p.m.
because he's so jewish well considering
they support they gin up our side state
yes I would say genocide you mean like
eugenics like we're talking about here
you abortion we went to a planned parent
artist thing you know why I'm sorry no I
don't all right
oh do you mean that the Jews supports
Israel's right to exist and that's what
makes them an alt right not see a bunch
of white Europeans coming into a place I
haven't been to and thousands of years
it's a whole day they have the
birthright which I'm a jab the first
right to discriminate against calcu Jews
Christians GOP ins or opinions oh yeah
oh right yes of Israel there's a
represent of the models of Judea right
of course well no it's only addressing
your point that he's an alt and this
light alright not see but Palestinian
Muslims have it better in Israel than
Palestinian Muslims and Palestine but
why are you protesting why are you
protesting me and not since you want to
come on come on come on what's your name
sir what's your name sir no okay just no
I'm not good okay would you like to come
and sit down you have to give your name
[Music]
you don't have to know whole thing you
don't think about your name but I do I
do think that if we're going to shout
out accusations and disrupt conversation
that's occurring that's productive
dialogue you're here to shut me down
hey Maddie we'll be right back it's
going to be a little longer than I
anticipated but I promise it already
you're here
you're here to shut down conversation
you believe that the right thing to do
is shut down people who disagree with
you people who supports violence
what can you finish it for are you I can
you finish your phrase and you just have
a stroke listen I don't mean to be
insulting here but just make a point
okay how many comes how about you come
step down here we can talk I mean
literally you're on a pedestal with you
all the family what you support okay
I support violet what what gives you the
right to shut down a coming for one this
hopeful pro-life when you're it's really
about denying health care to lower class
women that is what it's about that is
what it is about defunding Planned
Parenthood is about defunding health
care for the people who most need it you
know I have no accident I was pro-life
violence we talk about oh I don't follow
you said violence you said I support
violent what what do I support less
important I support violence what you
are justifying you're shutting down of
conversations we've intelligence with
plenty of people who disagree with me
yeah they act grown up so they can be on
your little show and make you thousands
of views and sell your little t-shirts
right here I'm not seeing right here
okay so you don't sell any merchandise
right not as I'd like it unlike your
other this is all a ploy by big
merchandise okay here's one thing let me
ask you I think it's very telling you
said I am here to shut I am NOT here to
come talk I am NOT here to express my
opinion he said this is what you said I
am here to shut down your conversation
oh yes so the intolerant left coming die
yes yes that's exactly what's happening
here but is it not oh yes oh yeah oh yes
so intolerant is shut down the
conversation now represents the status
quo of the liberal and conservative
establishment the whole
reason you're up sellers because on
college campus expressing a right-wing
point of view is not status quo brother
oh yes it is yes it is all they do south
I mean the proposing club TBSA oh by the
university yeah III you can do whatever
you want I just I would never try and
shut down your speech here's what I want
to ask you though if you could please
let me finish my dialogue with Maddie
I'll just don't shut down her space and
if you want to come sit down you can
come sit down okay okay okay all right
thank you very much thank you okay I
gotta go back to his mat hopefully
Maddie's still there
sorry about that Maddie everyone else
stay tuned for an actual discussion on
abortion on tomorrow's changed my mind
see you there I do appreciate that even
though you disagree with me you pulled a
wonderful prank by sending me to that
unstable gentleman hey if you like this
video subscribe or click one of these
videos playing in a box you know what
hit the notification bail because
subscriptions don't really mean anything
anymore especially if you're not 18 or
older at the very least logged into
YouTube as 18 or older because sometimes
people are 25 but they don't know how to
use the YouTube system properly and then
you never just take the notification pal
or you hate yourself